hello marianna your name is your name is
marianna
if you're refusing service no you're
you're discriminating and you're
breaking the law
and you can be personally sued you may
have seen this video that has gone viral
out of orange county california a couple
enters a yogurt shop
and threatens to sue the co-owner over
the mask mandate
mariana tabla can be heard on the video
explaining the policy
the man says he has a medical condition
and if she refuses to serve him
she can be sued for violating state law
that prohibits discrimination
by businesses now she's losing business
but many are standing behind her as well
saying the customers in the video were
in the wrong
it's an issue we're also seeing here
locally some las vegas restaurants
are having to deal with customers not
complying with all the coveted
guidelines
those owners tell eight news now with
covet cases increasing lately
in our state it is more important than
ever to follow the requirements
joe muller live in the las vegas strip
to tell us what those businesses
expect from the customer
most people don't have a problem wearing
a mask but some do forget to keep that
on when they walk around inside of a
restaurant while concerns are growing as
other states now
are implementing restrictions
wear face masks and stay socially
distant for months the guidelines have
been in place since restaurants were
permitted to reopen it's been
challenging
and we closed for a couple of months
ribby mosca owns me peru in henderson
reopening was not easy for him some
other states such as
illinois are closing indoor dining once
again with cases on the rise
moscow says most are complying with the
guidelines but says some are maybe
forgetting we are still in a pandemic
not big arguments with people but once
in a while we have people who
just don't don't feel comfortable he
says sometimes people not only forget
the mask rules but also forget something
else
it's not just a matter of having the
face mask once you are in the restaurant
besides you can remove your face mask if
you want to eat
but you have to understand the keeping
your distance is important too
signs are easy to spot outside of
eateries table 34 has them on the doors
we have to be in compliance with the
with the health codes and whatnot wes
kendrick is a chef at table 34
they are getting creative with extra
masks at the front if a customer
leaves it in the car or forgets it or
sometimes the ear straps break
you know we have we have a mask for them
while operating at 50 capacity fines
don't help the bottom line
i know a number of colleagues that have
already been fined
for not having masks whether it's an
employee
or allowing guests to mingle about
without
masks
and now back out here live there are
crews that actually go out to do
compliance checks for restaurants and
other businesses and as
you can imagine owners right now saying
a fine is something they really don't
need
reporting live here in the las vegas
strip joe moore 8 news now